so Zion I I don't even watch basketball
but even I have heard of Zion Williamson
he is Apparently one of the best
basketball players in the whole NBA he
he's I don't know freshman of the Year
something whatever they give the
basketball he's gotten some awards I
heard about him when he was in college
and I guess this man gets a lot of women
now I will say
I don't know why it's like if you date a
professional athlete
I don't want to say they're Pro they're
going to cheat on you because there are
athletes that are loyal
but I would say the odds are not in your
favor so if you go for that ladies I
would just be warned you're probably not
the only one
now Zion Zion had some women
like coming out about him giving
accusations and it's funny because they
always accuse the men
that don't need to abuse you that don't
need to Grape you that don't need to do
any of that like it's like these guys
have thrown at them 24 7. like you know
at basketball games there are women that
go run out hotels and try to get the men
to cheat on their wives they literally
they actively
hunt men they'll literally stalk them on
social media they'll they'll know
everything about these guys run into
them at the event and literally try to
get them to cheat on their wives
and and then they'll say oh but these
these guys are just like abusers it's
like what okay but there's this lady has
an accusation against him let's see
maybe it's probable maybe it sounds real
let's let's pull up the clip you guys I
literally did not want to come to the
internet and I'm just tired of saving
faith for this man that's completely
disrespecting me to the world and I
literally have to take this every time I
come on the internet people are bashing
me because of this man literally and I'm
tired of it he knows he he said he's
gonna send me 62 000 I have yet to
receive that since June I'm literally
here like he's literally a liar
you guys everything he says he's a liar
he's not who he says he is I literally
been saving face I did not want to come
to the world and let you guys know what
he has been doing to me my entire
relationship with him he is a woman
beater and the NBA needs to know this
laughs
I literally did not want to come to this
because I know he has so many
endorsements
but Zion Williamson is a woman beater oh
my God and the reason he was paying me
off is so I won't come to the world and
tell everybody
oh my God shut the [__]
you're telling me this guy needs to beat
women
the guy one of the best guys in the NBA
so much so that me who knows nothing
about the NBA knows who he is
you're telling me this guy needs to beat
women
like this [__] is just mad she didn't
get her 62 cat you notice that because
I'm sorry if you really cared about the
truth if you really care that he beat
women if you really wanted women to be
safe and cared about what was right what
was true you wouldn't accept money to
shut up
and then on top of that this lady is
fake crying like where are the tears if
anybody buys this at the NBA
please send them this video please
because I
she's fake crying the only reason she's
coming out is because she didn't get her
62k like I'm sorry if somebody beat me
you could not pay me to shut up
and and this lady has a full face of
makeup
I you know if you're just so emotional
and just so hurting about the abuse are
you gonna like beat down your face
full face of me like it's just this [__]
is so unbelievable yes the the NBA guys
just wake up and think I need to beat
women like it's like all right
does it happen sure
are there bad men sure but we need to
judge the women that come out and accuse
men just as harshly As we judge the men
for these crimes right now it is guilty
until proven innocent instead of
innocent until proven guilty these these
stories don't make sense you've been
asking him for sixty two thousand
dollars since June
why are you entitled to 62k either he
beat you or he didn't either you want
what's right or or you don't and to me
this idea that you're gonna beat down
your face
put on your sunglasses make sure your
nails are done and then go cry on camera
instead of like like this is the crazy
thing she posted on social media instead
of going to the police
why are you on social media instead of
the police because the police will
actually question you and talk about
your story if it doesn't be if it
doesn't match up why don't you go to the
NBA why do you need to expose him why
does everybody need to know why can't we
focus on the facts of the case
but yet a pretty woman comes on social
media and starts fake not even real
crime that's the worst part
could we at least get some real tears
like if you're gonna do this fake [__]
like could you at least learn how to cry
like
it's the dumbest anyways I don't believe
her you shouldn't believe her and women
that actually want Justice go to the
police they don't go to social media
and I think we should also
examine even further women on social
media that come forward with screenshots
messages because usually there's another
side of the story that they're not
telling
and these feminists will just convince
these women that they're victims and
just give them these words that mean
nothing and just confuse them and like
the women will weaponize the words
against the men
on another episode of women being
perfectly reasonable
and really easy to please as you know
women have very low standards we're
super easy to please we're just just
happy go lucky nurturing kind people